un rastro total de destrucción es lo que
dejo yo está como huracán de categoría 5
tras su paso por las islas colombianas
de san andrés y providencia el gobierno
colombiano informó que al menos el 98
por ciento de la infraestructura de
providencia quedó destruida
esta es una afectación grande y somos
conscientes que por primera vez en la
historia en nuestro país vemos un
huracán categoría 5 golpear nuestro
territorio y vamos a estar como gobierno
nacional hasta recuperar toda la
infraestructura en el menor tiempo
posible con vientos de 140 kilómetros
por hora el huracán impacto esta
madrugada en providencia que quedó
incomunicada por más de 14 horas en las
que el país temió por la suerte de los
cerca de 5000 habitantes de la isla el
gobierno informó de un plan de ayuda
humanitaria desde la ciudad costera de
cartagena de indias situada en el norte
de colombia en las próximas horas
estaremos despachando desde cartagena
una embarcación con material humanitario
y estaré acompañando a nuestro equipo la
armada nacional en ese propósito
cartagena y otras ciudades del norte de
colombia también
afectadas por el paso de yota la
tormenta ha dejado inundaciones en
distintos puntos de la región norte del
país y causado afectaciones a miles de
ciudadanos